so Peter before we got to TGS you kept
telling me about this game that you're
really excited to see I'd never heard
anything about it and we both got to
check it out it's called zodiac yeah
it's really interesting concept they
kind of gave us a little sneak peek get
some gameplay kind of little clothes
lift about it but it's cool what we see
in so far and it's just to hear your
thoughts on it so they've basically
partnered with some ex Final Fantasy
developers right including atocha
Sakamoto who is the composer of games
like phone evasive tactics holidays to
12 and they're also working with the
scenario writer from games like Final
Fantasy 10 and a few other ones like
these guys were responsible are some of
the best final fantasy games in the past
decade and what they're trying to do is
they're they're working with this studio
and a director who was a fan of their
games they're trying to make it like a
90s RPG and yes it's a mobile title for
some for most but it's also coming to
Vita and its potential to come to
consoles and it's supposed to be a
hybrid of Final Fantasy valkyrie profile
but is essentially like a melding of
these great Japanese RPGs that people
are fond of and you know maybe we
haven't seen something like it yeah I
mean it's definitely got the people
behind it to make this you know
something like really substantial and
interesting and something I really
enjoyed about it when I saw it for the
first time is the artistic style of it
it's 2d animated you can tell it and raw
and it's really beautiful it kind of
reminds me a little bit of child of
light not just in its beautiful world
that Tess it's kind of like it almost
looks like a watercolor painting style
but also in the mechanics and you're
kind of like flying on this Griffin
throughout the world and then it's turn
based right and you can't have fall into
the combat scenario again it's just
quite quite familiar from child of light
and man that game was great so it's
interesting to see how much of it it's
going to be like yeah it's going to be a
multiplayer game as well so you'll be
able to play with your friends online
they're not sure how it's going to work
like if you can play between I
did you see their kind of working on
those details you know you think zodiac
you think the zodiac signs and you are a
character that is trying to earn the
power of the twelve gods that are
represented of this like circular island
but different each section stupid sign
of the zodiac the zodiac also represents
for each sign a different class you can
change classes in battle in real time
and kind of cycle through days NASA keen
on took a turn based Japanese RPG with
kind of the child of light so the things
you described it's a little bit
reminiscent dragon's crown in its visual
style sort of big like bustling people
not busty but you know it's not sort of
approaching that like what you mean the
game is playable to show floor it's it's
so pretty earlier though so we'll see
where it's going to go it's been in
development about 12 months it's the
first time they've talked about it I
think he said they've got about another
year to go but that could change but I
think it's interesting to see these
Western developers working with the
Japanese team that's used to doing
consoles give especially because the
Japanese market is so mobile-focused so
it's sort of like luring them into not
luring them but bringing them into a
part of the industry of that they think
is a good business to be involved in but
they're doing it on an international
level rather than focusing on just the
Japanese side of things which let's be
honest like there aren't that many 90s
style Japanese RPGs anymore there's this
whole modern so the western arm of the
industry is sort of allowing them to do
things that they love and that talking
that's really good yeah